نعم يمكن القول ان مئات اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين خرجوا من مخيم عين الحلوه
بفعل استمرار هذه الاشتباكات ونحن رصدنا
قبل قليل من هذا المدخل مدخل التعمير عددا
من اللاجئين الفلسطينيين خرجوا من هذا
المدخل ولكن مياده على مقربه من مدخل مخيم
عين الحلوى هذا احد المراكز للاجئين
الفلسطينيين الذين نزحوا من داخل المخيم
يمكن ان نشاهد الجهود التي تقوم بها فراق
الاسعاف لنقل الاهالي من داخل مخيم عين
الحلو يمكن مشاهده هذا الرجل المقعد الذي
ينقل لتوه من داخل هذا المخيم المحاولات
حديثه والمطالبات من قبل الاسعاف لمدهم
بكل الحاجات التي يحتاجها عدد كبير من
اللاجئين يمكن مشاهده عدد من اللاجئين في
هذا المسجد مسجد الموصلي يتواجد نحو 500
لاج الفلسطينيين لا تتوفر لديهم الحد
الادنى من المساعدات كل ما يتم تقديمه
اليهم هو مجرد غذاء
للاستمرار في هذا المركز بعضهم وصل منذ
بدايه هذه الاشتباكات منذ ثلاثه ايام واذا
ما تقدمنا يمكن مشاهده ايضا المزيد من
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في تلك الرقعه
تحدثنا اليهم قبل قليل والصفوا الواقع
الذي شهدوه داخل المخيم خلال الايام
الماضيه بعضهم يعيشوا في الاحياء التي
تشهد اشتباكات وقالوا ان هناك خوفا حقيقيا
من استمرار هذه الاشتباكات في المرحله
المقبله يمكن مشاهده عدد كبير من الاطفال
والنساء الذين كل جل ما قدم اليهم يقتصر
على الغذاء والمياه ليس لديهم حتى مكان
ينام وحتى الادويه بعضهم يعاني من امراض
مزمنه وبعضهم ايضا يعاني من اوضاع صحيه
يمكن ايضا هنا مشاهده ايضا بعض المقعدين
الذين هم بحاجه لمعونه لمعونه صحيه ولدعم
صحي وادويه وايضا اذا ما دخلنا الى داخل
هذه القاعه يمكن ان نشاهد عددا كبيرا من
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الذين فروا من داخل
هذا المخيم هذا كل ما يملكونه هذه هي
الفراشه التي قدمت لهم ما يدا يعني من
خلال حادثك معهم ووقوفك على الواقع الذي
تنقولي له الان ما اكبر مخاوف هؤلاء مع
استمرار الاشتباكات داخل المخيم حتى هذه
اللحظات التي اطل بها ايضا ايهاب العقدي
في مراسلته
مياده بطبيعه الحال هم يخافون كثيرا من
استمرار هذه الاشتباكات لان استمرار هذه
الى الاشتباكات يعني بقائهم في هذه
الاماكن الاونروا اليوم فتحت عددا من
المدارس بالنسبه اليهم ولكن كما يمكنك
مشاهده وكما تظهر في عدسه الكاميرا
الاوضاع الصعبه جدا بالنسبه لهؤلاء
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الفلسطينيين هم اصلا
كانوا يعانون من اوضاع صعبه واتت هذه
الاشتباكات لتفاقم من معاناتهم تحدثوا عن
قلق وخوف حقيقي من استمرار هذه الاشتباكات
خاصه انه لغايه الان وفق ما قالوا لنا ان
كل المساعي تصطدم بواقع او حتى تصطدموا
بعدم
نيه لوقف هذه الاشتباكات وهذا الامر
بطبيعه الحال يثير قلقهم هم ايضا يتحدثون
عن انه اذا ما استمرت الاحوال على ما هي
عليه فما هو مستقبلهم ومن سيقدم لهم
المعونات التي يحتاجونها في المستقبل من
داخل احد المساجد الذي التي لجا اليها اذا
هؤلاء الذين نزحوا من داخل مخيم عين
الحلوه في صيدا مراسله الجزيره كارمن نجوى
شكرا جزي